a long time daily I'm Brian buckmeyer a
Snapchat video Paul Murdoch sent to
friends in the hours before he was
murdered was played for the jury in his
father Alec Murdoch's murder trial as
long crimes Angela Levy tells us that
video is important to the timeline in
the case
representative from from chat testified
about when Paul Murdoch sent that video
to his friend the night of June 7th
2021. uh this this video was first seen
on memories on June 7th 2021 at 7 39
hours okay Eastern the video shows Alec
Murdock in a blue shirt and tan pants
later on in the night when he talks to
law enforcement he's wearing a white
T-shirt prosecutors have called the
video critical to their case while it
was stored at 7 39 PM when was it
actually sent it was sent on same day
June 7 2021 at 23 or I'm sorry 7 56
hours Eastern Time the video was sent 17
minutes after it was stored the defense
suggesting that lapse in time is
important to them can you see on the
screen the metadata for this file
yes and does it say uh June the 7th 2021
at 7 30 18.
and so this this was shot of basically a
minute before it was uploaded is that
correct it appears so yeah and I'm sorry
if that seems sticky but in this case
you know every minute and every second
you know can matter
um
does uh Snapchat keep a list of and it
might be getting the terminology around
friends Alec Murdoch's attorneys say he
didn't kill Paul and Maggie someone else
did and they suggested on
cross-examination that anyone who could
see Paul's Snapchat video that night
knew exactly where he was I'm Anjanette
Levy reporting from Walterboro South
Carolina for Law and crime daily
a big decision on the way from Judge
Clifton Newman he heard arguments from
the prosecution and testimony from
witnesses to decide if evidence of
alleged Financial crimes committed by
Murdoch can come in the state alleges
that Alec Murdock murdered Maggie and
Paul to distract from Financial
misconduct he accused he's accused of
stealing millions of dollars from his
former law firm and from accounts set up
to hold money for clients as part of
settlements since he has not been
convicted of those charges his defense
team wanted that information kept out
but when Murdoch's lawyers asked
Witnesses what motive Murdoch could have
had to kill his wife and son the judge
says they opened the door for the
financial crime allegations to come in
the Chief Financial Officer for the firm
testified out of the presence of the
jury she says the firm had a meeting
with Murdoch to confront him about
missing money but he got a call that his
father was in hospice and had to rush
out that night Maggie and Paul were
killed
when the murders happened that the the
inquiry nobody was going to bring that
up now in the wake of the murders the
fair speeds that you had talked to Alec
about the morning that Maggie and Paul
were killed correct that's right it's a
family-like place
um everybody was concerned for him his
family we knew we had time to discuss
this before the end of the year and at
that point like we said we didn't think
we were stealing any money from us
we're a good reason at that time to
think he was stealing that's right and
so it did get shelled correct that's
correct
I'm joined by co-host and a former trial
Attorney Terry Austin as well as special
guest trial mediator Dina doll Terry one
second the jury's in court the next they
are excused and the judge holds a
hearing about whether Financial records
should come in can you break down the
mechanics of this hearing sure this was
what the judge called an in-camera
hearing and it's a Latin word it just
means in Chambers now generally you have
these kind of hearings in the chambers
but he had it in the courtroom so the
public was there but the jury was not
there and the reason the judge does not
want the jury to hear all this evidence
before he makes a decision now he could
have made this decision prior to the
trial but he said no we're going to wait
to see and what happened the door was
open because the defense asked a
question about motive so I think this
was wise on the judge's part at this
point and we'll see what happens we're
going to listen to other Witnesses and
ultimately he's going to make a decision
and he said look I'm going to give you
time to bring these Witnesses in I don't
want to be reversed right Dina notice
decision yet more witnesses to come but
whether or not the jury we hear this
financial crimes what do you think will
happen and what did you hear think about
the arguments on either side
now from hearing the Witnesses on the
stand so far they haven't helped the
prosecution very much the prosecution
has to show that this evidence is more
probative than prejudicial that it is
these Financial crimes if he did it are
connected to the murder and their
Witnesses are not really giving that
kind of evidence yet we'll see what
other Witnesses they put forward but it
is rather prejudicial this idea of
having Financial crimes but so far
they're not linking the money to the
victims and they have to link it more I
think in order for the judge to let any
of it in yeah it seems like the
arguments are running parallel to each
other not exactly intersecting but more
witnesses to come we'll see another big
story making headlines right now a 30
year old councilwoman in New Jersey is
dead Sean killed outside her home
Wednesday night please found Eunice Dom
for in her car with multiple gunshot
wounds they believe her car traveled
about 100 feet after the shooting
hitting two-part car course the
Republican councilwoman was elected to a
three-year term in Sayreville New Jersey
in 2021. dumfor was a single mother to a
12 year old daughter and had just gotten
married after Thanksgiving while police
have said they do believe dwemfor was
targeted they have not released a motive
a rookie football player who was
supposed to suit up for the Super Bowl
is instead on the commissioner exempt
list for now Josh Sills was indicted on
one count of rape and another count of
kidnapping sales is an offensive lineman
with the Philadelphia Eagles a woman
told police in Ohio back in 2019 that
Sills was giving her and her cousin a
ride home around 2 A.M the victim report
she had known Sills for several years
and they went to high school together
she told police that when her cousin got
out seals pulled her back into the truck
with him and groped her she alleges he
forced her to perform oral sex before
eventually letting her go
Sills is due back in court February 16th
just days after the Philadelphia Eagles
are set to take on the Kansas City
Chiefs in the Super Bowl
while he's on the exempt list sales
cannot practice play or travel with a
team
Nathan chasing the horse one of the
actors who starred in the movie dancing
with Wolves will remain in jail without
bond for now he was arrested in Las
Vegas on sex abuse charges chasing
horses reportedly the leader of a cult
known as the as the circle he was taken
multiple wives many of them under the
age of 16 chasing whores allegedly
convinced victims that assaults were
part of Native American traditions and
that he was a holy Medicine Man Records
show when Las Vegas Police searched his
home they found a memory of cards with
videos of sexual assaults as well as
guns and more than 40 pounds of
marijuana and mushrooms
Florida's governor wants to change State
rules to make it easier to send
convicted criminals to death row this
comes after the high-profile trial of
the Parkland High School shooter in that
case in a 9-3 decision a jury opted to
spare the life of the young man who
killed 17 people at his former High
School in 2018. he got life in prison
instead Governor Ron DeSantis urged
Republican lawmakers to introduce
legislation to allow the jury to choose
the death penalty with only eight of the
12 jurors in favor of it right now the
decision to send as the defendant to
death must be unanimous bills filed in
the Florida House and Senate are
expected to be taken up when the
legislative session starts in March
Terry the U.S Supreme Court has taken up
a similar issue in death penalty cases
and has even made decisions about
capital punishment in Florida tell us
about it yes so before 2016 Florida
allowed juries to vote for capital
punishment by a majority vote of just
seven of five back then judges could
even override the jury's decision and
impose death but the United States
Supreme Court struck down the Florida
law in 2016 in the Hearst versus Florida
case the Court held that the sixth
amendment requires a jury not a judge to
find quote each fact necessary to impose
death So based on that decision Florida
passed a new sentencing law requiring a
unanimous jury recommendation to the
judge to impose the death sentence now
after weighing the aggravating and
mitigating Factor so in 2020 the Florida
Supreme Court said the legislature went
way too far interpreting the Hearst case
it ruled that the Hearst decision did
not require unanimous jury decision on
death just the United mysterious
decision that the defendant was eligible
for death because of the aggravating
Factor so you know it is possible Brian
that the Florida law could be modified
but if it is I expect there's going to
be a challenge to the Supreme Court yeah
I can see that challenge as well the
thing I don't like about it is that it
seems like he's just moving the goal
polls one more what if it's I don't know
it's nine to three now it's eight to
four later seven to five another time is
it just gonna keep pushing the goal post
the prosecutions didn't carry their case
I think that's the issue don't change
the law to try to help out the the
prosecution during the sentencing phase
of the Parkland Shooters trial many
family members understandably spoke out
about the jury's decision not to give
the shooter the death penalty
he has escaped being managed to the
fullest extent of the law as I believe
he should have been
knowing he gets to live out the rest of
his Natural Life
something Elena doesn't get to do
because of his disgusting and violent
actions on February 14 2018.
he has escaped this punishment because a
minority of the jury was given the power
to overturn the majority decision
made by people who were able to see him
for what he is
a remorseless monster
who deserves no mercy
Dina if the rules in Florida do change
would that affect the Parkland School
Shooter's case and if scotus takes the
case what do you think that was side
it wouldn't affect his applying a law
like that retroactively would certainly
violate his due process even if they
tried I imagine that would get reversed
on appeal so it would really be for
cases moving forward and in terms of the
Supreme Court you know are this makeup
that the Supreme Court has changed even
since that earlier ruling and and that's
what happened so I could see a flora
isn't the only law if passing this that
doesn't require unanimous juries so the
fact that um the other state that still
exists that hasn't gone overturned most
likely if Florida passes this law it
will get upheld we'll see how it plays
out